so what I believe you were trying to say
is thank you thank you you're welcome
what no no no I I didn't I was it why
would I ever I
me I see what's happening
yeah you're face to face with greatness
and it's strange you don't even know how
you feel it's adorable well it's nice to
see that humans never change open your
eyes let's begin yes it's really me it's
my breathe it in I know it's a lot the
hair the B when you're staring at a
demig god what can I say except you're
welcome for the tides the sun the sky
hey it's okay it's okay you're
welcome I'm just an ordinary J guy hey
what has two thumbs and pulled up the
sky when you were waddling y hi this guy
when when the night's got cold Who Stole
You fire from down below looking at him
yo oh also I last so the sun you're
welcome to stretch your days and bring
you fun also I
heartness the breeze You're welcome to
fill your sails and shake your trees so
what can I say except you're welcome for
the islands I ped from the sea there's
no need to pray it's okay you're welcome
H I guess it's just my way of being me
you're welcome you're
welcome well come to think of it kid
honestly I could go on and on I could
explain every natural phenomenon the
tith the grass the ground oh that was Ma
just messing around I killed a Neil I
bured it guts sprouted a tree now you
got coconuts what's the lesson what is a
takeaway don't mess with Maui when he's
on a breakaway and the tempestry here in
my skin it's a map of the victories I
win look where I've been I make
everything happen look at that me m
to hey well anyway let me say you're
welcome for the wonderful world you know
hey it's okay it's okay you're welcome
you're welcome well come to think of it
I got to go hey it's your day to say
you're
welcome cuz I'm going to need that boat
I'm sailing way away you're
welcome now we can't do everything but
close you're
welcome
welcome and thank
you
hi